THE STATE OF YOUTUBE:
YouTube has become pay to win. Gone are the days
that random joes could pick up cameras and record
themselves playing games or discussing a topic.
Nowadays, everyone from MKBHD and MrWhoseTheBoss
to Airrack and MrBeast spend tens of thousands
if not hundreds of thousands on each and every
video. They also all have millions of dollars
worth of equipment, dedicated studies, and dozens
of employees. At this point, they’re pretty much
just full on production studios and that’s
on the personality side of YouTube itself.
Then, you have the whole company side as well with
channels like Bright Side, The Infographics Show,
T Series, and Cocomelon Nursery Rhymes.
There are a few outliers who have stuck to
a reasonable level of production like SSSniperWolf
and Penguin but these are very much the exception,
not the rule. Also, most of these guys were OGs
to YouTube. Trying to replicate their formula
today from scratch probably wouldn’t work
all that well. This is quite a shame as this
characteristic is what made YouTube different from
traditional media platforms in the first place.
People liked that they could see their favorite
creators without censorship, without filters,
and without advertiser influence. People liked
the genuine, vulnerable, and authentic nature
of YouTube, but modern creators shy away from
these characteristics as much as possible. These
attributes simply lead to drama, controversy,
and potentially getting cancelled. So, the best
solution is to just stay as vanilla as possible.
Never have an opinion, never push the boundaries,
and never ever piss off the twitter people. Larger
creators are simply leaning into these attributes
as it allows them to outsource more work, create
a better distinction between their personal lives
and their online personas, and it gives them
a larger moat against aspiring up and coming
creators. So, a pretty smart strategy from their
end but this is arguably destroying the essence of
YouTube. So, here’s how YouTube became pay to
win and the upsetting future of the platform.
CREATORS GET SQUEEZED:
Taking a look back, the roots of this evolution
can be traced back to the mid 2010s to creators.
By this point, most niches had already become
saturated with tons of creators. People were
starting to understand YouTube could not only
be a viable career but a lucrative one that
came with popularity, fame, and influence. So,
it’s no wonder why people were jumping at every
opportunity they saw but this brought along with
it quite a few challenges. Larger creators often
struggled to keep up with the quantity of content
from smaller creators. It was also super difficult
to think of original ideas as every topic you
can think of had already been covered from every
aspect you can think of. The saying “There are no
original ideas” was truer than ever. But despite
this, creators attempted to keep up with the
YouTube machine leading to burnout and high levels
of stress and depression. A few notable creators,
however, were able to find an escape from this
vicious hamster wheel. These guys accepted
that they would never be able to keep up with
the firehouse of content that was being put up on
YouTube. If they were a tech YouTuber, there was
simply too many smartphones, laptops, and gadgets
coming out to cover them all. If they were a
vlogger, it was simply impossible to make their
life interesting every single day of the year.
This was simply not sustainable, so these creators
decided to take another path. Instead of trying to
cover every single topic, they decided to simply
cover one topic better than anyone. The idea is
that people would tune in not because the ideas or
concepts were unique but because the delivery was
exceptional. A great example of this is Marques
Brownlee. Somewhere along the line, Marques
decided to drop a quarter million dollars on a
robotic camera. Let me just say, there is no way
to quantifiably justify this investment. You can’t
be like, oh this camera is going to increase my
viewership by 6.2% so in 42 months, the ROI will
be net positive. It simply doesn’t work because
it’s unlikely that this camera led to any sort
of noticeable increase in viewership, atleast not
in the short term, but that’s ok. This camera was
not purchased to boost viewership. This camera was
purchased to build a brand, a perception. Whenever
you see a crazy camera shot on tech YouTube,
you know its Marques. And this association gets
his one step closer to being the undisputed king
of tech youtubers. So, the next time when an
iPhone drops, it doesn’t matter if a hundred
people post reviews about it before Marques. You
can bet that millions of people are waiting to
see Marques’ take specifically because he provides
and experience that they can’t get anywhere else
on YouTube. Marques is by no means the only one
leveraging this strategy. This strategy has become
very prevalent with Mr Beast’s channel as well.
Take a few of his recent videos for example: $1 vs
$500,000 Plane Ticket and $1 vs $1,000,000 Hotel
Room. These are by no means ground breaking video
ideas. BuzzFeed made identical videos 6 years ago
about planes and hotels. In fact, they had a full
on series comparing cheap options to expensive
options. Yet, Mr Beast’s plane video got 150
million views and his hotel video got 217 million
views. Why? Simple, his scale and production.
Those are just 2 examples but I could name
dozens. MrWhoseTheBoss, Airrack, Magnates Media,
Good Mythical Morning, Mark Rober, StuffMadeHere,
Film Theory, JianHao Tan, Wong Fu Productions, and
basically every other large channel you can think
of. While their initial success may have been
fueled by down to earth mortal videos, its their
production quality that has kept them at the top.
AUDIENCES EVOLVE:
It’s not just the creators who who evolved
either. Audiences have also very much evolved.
Back in 2007 and 2008, let me just be real
here, the people who watched YouTube were
a bunch of antisocial nerds and gamers. But
nowadays, everyone watches YouTube and with
that comes along a vastly different set of
expectations. Most people are used to TV,
Netflix, and movies, and to them, that
level of production is normal. So,
naturally, these people flock to channels
that are able to live up these standards.
Also, let me say, this is not a trend that’s
unique to YouTube. In general, people flock
to high production value content. Take Avatar 2
for example. The storyline was at best mundane,
but this has proved to be completely irrelevant as
Avatar 2 ended up as the 3rd highest grossing film
of all time. The same thing could be said about
the original Avatar as well. While the storyline
was more substantial than Avatar 2, critics argue
that it was just a rip off of Dances With Wolves.
This is very much true and even James
Cameron himself has admitted this, but
that didn’t stop Avatar from becoming the highest
grossing film of all time. Why you ask? Well,
the visuals are stunning, the world building is
unbelievable, and you forget that it’s even CGI.
Now, this isn’t to say that Cameron or creators
should come up with crappy storylines and buff it
up with the visuals. Not a good strategy. Ideally,
the story is good and the production is good. That
would obviously lead to the best results. But,
the thing to note is that a good production can
make up for a bad story. A good story, however,
doesn’t always make up for a bad production.
Another great example of this is the Grand Theft
Auto series. The GTA series has been around for
25 years at this point and while there are some
differences between the games like the city that
its based in, it all boils down to the same
thing. You’re a bad guy doing bad things to
make money and earn respect. Simple as that.
But despite milking the same plot for so long,
GTA V ended up becoming the highest grossing
piece of media of all time, pulling in $7.7
billion. And we can only imagine how well GTA VI
will perform. The reasoning is simple. Rockstar
Games is constantly creating an unmatchable
experience with each and every iteration.
So, when audiences are constantly being fed
this level of content by movies, TV shows,
and games, it’s only natural that they come
to expect the same from YouTube. The creators
that are able to keep up do exceptionally well.
The others, well, the others are left behind.
YOUTUBE ADAPTS:
Creators often like to blame the algorithm when
it comes to a video not performing well or their
channel being killed off. Audiences also like to
complain that platforms are recommending thirst
traps and low productivity content. But, the
truth is that both of these parties are just
shifting the blame. The algorithms of social media
platforms are nothing but audience psychology. So,
if a video isn’t performing well or a channel
is receiving less views, it’s not because
the algorithm doesn’t like the content, it’s
because the audience doesn’t like the content,
atleast not a broad audience. The opposite is true
as well. If a channel is performing really well,
it’s not because YouTube is biased or something.
It’s because that’s what the audience wants to
see. And based on the biggest creators
today, it’s clear that what the audience
wants is fast paced high production value
content which brings us to our main question:
where does that leave small creators? Well, not
in a good place. Also, when I say small creators,
I don’t mean people with hundreds of thousands
of subscribers or even tens of thousands. I’m
talking about people who are trying to get their
first thousand subscribers, their first 5 thousand
subscribers. As Casey Neistat once said, the
hardest part of any creator’s journey is getting
the first 10,000 subs. And this is harder than
ever today because top creators have simply
set the bar for entry so high. Now, there’s no
point is blaming these creators. Not only do they
produce awesome content that’s enjoyed by hundreds
of millions of people but they’re just doing
what’s best for their brands and their businesses.
That’s only reasonable. But, with that being said,
this trend has largely shifted the tide against
new creators. In fact, 97% of YouTubers don’t
make it, which is not that different from
Hollywood where only 2% of actors make it.
Most small creators nowadays are hoping for that
one viral video that will explode their channel,
but this is not that different from actors
and musicians hoping for that one lucky break.
Now, a lot of creators will have you believe
that it’s not luck and that it comes down to
one’s understanding of YouTube and the
audience. Mr Beast has even claimed that
he could get to a 1 million subscribers from
zero within 3 to 4 months. And they’re right,
succeeding on YouTube is not necessarily luck
but the thing to note is that creators that are
starting off also don’t have the same skills or
mindset. It’s like those shows where millionaires
try to start from zero and become a millionaire
again. Admittedly, these are super interesting
to watch but to think that a homeless guy could
do it just because a millionaire could is absurd.
Similarly, thinking that an average joe could
get a million subscribers in 3 months or even
an year just because Mr Beast could is also
absurd. Of course, there will be exceptions
but that’s what they are exceptions. The harsh
reality is that making it on YouTube is becoming
harder and harder everyday because the bar
for entry is also becoming higher and higher.
THE FUTURE OF YOUTUBE:
In the end, the state of YouTube today is not
out of the ordinary by any means. That’s how
every other artistic industry has always
been whether that be games, movies, TVs,
writing, or art itself. The reason that this is
upsetting with YouTube though is because YouTube
used to be the exception. They started off like
BeReal, but expecting them to stay this was is
simply unrealistic. BeReal is already dying and if
YouTube chose this path, they too would probably
be dead. The reason that YouTube is so successful
today is because they evolved. They became more
like traditional media and the creators
followed suit. With that being said though,
if you’re able to make it to the other side, the
opportunity on YouTube is insane. But, getting to
the otherside is harder than ever because YouTube
has become pay to win. Do you prefer the old
YouTube or the new YouTube? Comment that down
below. Also, drop a like if you appreciate the
higher production quality. And of course, consider
checking out our discord community to suggest
future video ideas and consider subscribing
to see more questions logically answered.